that scene in episode one the doctor's
thing
yeah did that really happen yeah my mum
will kill me for telling this because it
was my uh
uh our family doctors and i
he'd been our family my doctor since i
was a child
but i went as an adult because
i was there's something wrong with my
bum
when you said bum you looked at me
directly in the eyes
i'm sorry i'm aroused and
[Laughter]
was i said there's this thing wrong with
my bum and he went okay
and i went so what'd you think he goes
well
it'll probably be all right and i said
well
i would really like it i'd like you to
just
if you could make me feel better about
if i feel better that it will be all
right
and he went it um it'll probably clear
itself up
and i said yeah but is there any way i
could be sure and he went ah
you want me to put my finger up there
don't you
know if it's not magically necessary
and the other i think maybe maybe
there's a reason but what is the reason
that you film it
in the school you used to teach in i
think it's therapy probably
i'm in the actual classroom where i talk
because i was just to keep the theme
going
a real teacher for a long time yeah i
taught for yeah
six years in the school that we film it
in the classroom that i'm going mad in
and i
that's that's really well that was my
classroom yeah but you did it
did you ever enjoy it was there ever a
moment when you thought oh i like this
i don't know okay
look i've met some very nice people
there and the kids must've liked you you
were nominated for teacher of the year
weren't you yes i was great
i was yeah you know yes i've told this
story many times
teacher of the year is a very
prestigious award that's taken very
seriously and rightly by the
hard-working teaching community
and my head teacher called me in and he
was wetting himself laughing
he couldn't stop laughing for the first
10 minutes and he went
i went what why have you called me here
he goes you've been
um
you've been known i've got this
a teacher of the year awards have been
nominated
and i went oh okay and it was by a very
sweet girl called gemma i've humiliated
many times
and it's a six-page document that people
have to fill in
for the reasons why you should be
nominated for teacher of the year
it was blank aside from one sentence
that she'd written on it
which was of the reasons why you think
he should be teacher of the year and
she'd written
he's a well good laugh and he don't make
us do no work
only recently we were at a bbc party
we showed that glass of wine it was fun
between us and we met that lovely lady
oh i'm surprised you're bringing that
lady up are we allowed to bring that
lady up well you tell me it's your show
well i don't know
but it happened to you not me so you
tell them
what bit of okay this lady came up to us
we're at a bbc party she came up to the
tour we were chatting sharing our wine
straws and uh she went i do disability
at the bbc
whatever that means and then she looked
at him
and what did she say to you well she
said that i qualify
and it was a hype thing not good
what a challenge since we had that
meeting when the lady told me that i was
technically as far as the bbc is
concerned disabled
i had a member of a council i won't know
where tell me
that i could get a parking badge
the rest of the couch is so jealous
right now
parking pads thanks for that
i won't forget the day that ryan gosling
high-fived me
because i'm officially disabled
the school trip seems like that's when
all rules go out the window
for pupils everybody and for teachers i
think
yeah i think you've got to remember when
i first started teaching i was 21
21 years of age you know and you said i
was sent to paris on a school trip
three of us all of us in our early 20s
in charge of uh
bus loads of kids is i mean it's frankly
amoral
what'd you get up to you know it's awful
i can say it now
i'm never going to go back to teaching
now right
and i got really drunk with two friends
in a hotel room when the kids were all
in bed like
really drunk we'd had a bottle of
tequila between the three of us
and um then i heard kids running around
it's so bad isn't it
her kids running around and i'm quite
good at pretending to be sober when i'm
not so i said i'll i'll go out and i'll
deal with this to my
to my friend tony
who's still a teacher
hello and i went out and there were
these kids all in their
90s in pajamas all giggling and i went
out what's going on here like i'm sorry
sorry sorry i said you know you should
be in your bedroom it's absolutely
disgraceful and i was doing a beautiful
job
when tony came out of my room and i
don't know why he was just in his boxer
a really big pair of boots start going
like this you should be in bed
and i grabbed him by the face i was so
frightened i grabbed him on the face i
just pushed him
into my room i closed the door one of
the kids went is that mr stephen
yes he's not feeling very well i
accepted it
are you all romantic man are you no i've
given up on it
it stopped for me romance when i was
about 22 when i
i bought a girlfriend back from college
so
my parents got really nice um garden and
they were away
so i thought this is this is perfect
we'll go and sit in the garden and i
made you a picnic i took some food not
pig nipples but i hadn't been introduced
to them yet
i think there's some food out there and
in the sun and
there was grass and sun and one thing
led to another
i love that i love that line she was
wearing it was really romantic i don't
want to go into details i don't want to
make anyone bring their
pig nipples up but um she had a long
flowing skirt and
she sat atop me
and things started to like a toilet roll
holder yeah a little bit like that yeah
okay like a really romantic toilet
so she was there and it was really
romantic and the breeze and lovely and
and i thought well this is awesome this
is one of the most romantic things
that's ever happened between two people
then my uh granddad came around the
corner
honestly i'm not making up and he'd
never met her before
so he came around hello you too
she couldn't get off because it was
happening
and you could see him thinking she's
really rude of them both it's a really
separate room
because i've never met her before surely
she should stand up she couldn't
so it was a full 15 minutes oh yeah
with her like this i mean that's not
vince i would dig liam
in her
my granddad making polite conversation
that was the day i gave up on romance
that would kill romance yeah okay there
we go
so i hit that yeah okay
it didn't talk this afternoon what's
happened to it
shut up
[Applause]
do you have any tips because you're in
high heels should i take him off
no not sure we're taking this very
seriously
he's he's talking to me
i mean no run-ups if you want to take
them off
whatever you wasn't even thinking about
run-up
so rachel go for it no no don't don't
take your shoes off yeah i just hit like
a girl in these
yeah so competitive
[Applause]
she slips
[Applause]
are you left or right-handed uh right
right so you know right
leg back so you really get the whole
right leg back
and the aim is just to hit it so it goes
away it goes you do that you go
boom and it goes back up okay i
honestly mine was so bad so uh let's see
what rachel gets and then i'll decide if
i'm going to do it
yeah you get a score you get a score you
got to score left
leg forward yeah yeah are you in range
though are you in range i don't know
like should i find out is that
come forward a bit come forward a bit
because you want to remember your aim
is to punch through the bag through so i
want to go like that yes i like that
i just hit it in the middle come on
[Applause]
okay here we go here we go okay we have
what do i need two 182 to beat 182
loving it
does it terribly when you don't care and
then you do yeah
can't i just have a stare down
and it's who laughs first right um
okay
[Applause]
oh
here we go here we go here we go
wow
okay
what was yours eight i think it was
three thousand
that was six seven two was it what six
seven two
six three two so if you don't beat that
tightly
i mean look at this
okay okay here we go here we go this
same technique the world champion
were you channeling the god of love when
you had this picture taken
magnificent that's amazing do you think
i look magnificent yeah i think it's
beautiful
i may put that on my posters i
personally think i look like a drop
[Music]
trifle
i saw my two nieces this weekend just
gone and they are
um six years old and two years old and
the first things they both said to me
before hello
the first niece went uncle greg we're
not allowed to talk about your fat tummy
anymore
and then it was a beat and the
three-year-old went
you are fat
this is the best pure honesty
[Applause]
it's taller we're taller yeah
okay okay and uh now maybe i'll be
turning up to get us in the mood
you gotta say the mood uh ken brown is
going to give us uh
just a little bit of form before we do
this okay you do your face off do your
face off come on come on okay off you go
ladies and gentlemen on the left they
call him the postman because he always
delivers it's the undisputed
heavyweight champion of the world
anthony joshua
[Music]
[Applause]
how is he looking at
because he sometimes delivers
unless he gets stuck in traffic
it is greg man mountain david
so here we go here we go so aj
yes you go first ah well that's not as
heavy i thought that was gonna be
heavier
okay
okay okay you go first you go for it
mind the cameras here we go
it's all golf whoa
oh dear
thank you
[Laughter]
come on
[Music]
you